bonsoir par icm alors merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france alors
madagascar il ya eu confinement puis
déconfinement et l'art confinement on
imagine que c'est compliqué dans quel
état d'esprit et la population alors
bonsoir à tous oui effectivement on a eu
un premier confinement à la fin du mois
du mois de mars qui n'a pas été très
efficace parce qu'il y avait très peu de
casse bonbons la madagascar et lundi la
population était confiné donc les gens
sont malheureusement l'économie est
assez informelle et donc ils sont
obligés de travailler pour se nourrir on
ne peut pas dire qu'il ya encore de
tension mais on ne peut craindre que ça
arrive c'est les mesures sont l'air
assez strict jusqu'à 4000 militaires qui
ont été déployés dans la capitale et les
villes voisines pour contre harnes
justement les malgaches à ne plus
circuler comment ça se passe sur place
il y à des amendes effectivement on ne
peut vraiment plus sortir son peine
d'être arrêté par des militaires alors à
partir de 14h parce qu'il ya un
couvre-feu qui met en place à partir de
14 heures juste pour tananarive les
autres districts sont gérés d'une façon
différente
je sais pas j'ai pas fait l'expérience
je ne connais pas de personnes qui l'ont
fait qu'il soit arrêté par des
militaires
mais effectivement il est interdit de
circuler et il n'y a personne dans les
rues sauf pour ce qui concerne les
véhicules de ravitaillement des magasins
de preuves de produits de première
nécessité sur place est ce qu'on arrive
à expliquer pourquoi justement les
choses se sont aggravées à nouveau
puisqu'il ya eu un confinement comme en
france qui a une bon résultat
est ce qu'il ya eu un relâchement les
malgaches n'ont pas pris peut-être la
mesure de la gravité n'ont pas respecté
les gestes bavière barrière en tout cas
comment peut-on l'expliquer alors je
pense que j'ai activement les malgaches
ont connu un certain relâchement au
monde dans la crise les dirigeants du
pays n'ont pas forcément été plus clair
possible la dangerosité de la situation
et puis encore une fausse et d'économie
informelle
la plupart des habitants du pays n'ont
pas le choix que de travailler pour se
nourrir et au jour le jour
donc au bout d'un moment ils sont
obligés de sortir de leur maison et de
se mêler à la foule après mon pote que
oui est-ce que pardonnez moi est ce que
justement ils ont des masques il ya des
mesures de protection qui sont
organisées peut-être voilà dans
certaines entreprises vous dites les
gens sont obligés d'aller travailler
certes mais on est ce qu'ils sont
protégés au moins alors dans la capitale
on peut voir que les gens portent les
masques et respectent les mesures
barrières
dès qu'on s'éloigne un petit peu on voit
que c'est moins le cas
mais sur place et dans les entreprises
locales ou les gens sont obligés de
travailler
il y a des il ya des règles qui sont
mises en place pour que les malgaches
respectent les mesures barrières alors
on imagine vous l'avez d17 une économie
qui est parfois voilà compliqué vous
même vous aviez trouvé un travail
pendant le déconfinement hélas plus rien
on imagine que c'est la situation de
beaucoup de malgaches et que ça peut
être extrêmement compliqué est ce qu'il
ya au moins des aides d'état sur place
comme il ya eu en france on ça n'existe
pas alors oui ça peut être assez
compliqué ensuite les aides d'état sont
sont allouées aux familles et aux gens
qui sont vraiment vraiment besoin on
peut pas dire que les choses soient
claires et que l'on sache vraiment qui a
accès ou pas et quelles sont les
conditions pour y avoir accès en tout
cas dans le secteur privé
l'état n'intervient que très très peu
merci beaucoup tarik mallard en tout cas
nous avoir apporté votre témoignage
puis à madagascar où je le rappelle donc
on confine la population après un regain
de coronavirus merci à vous